what is more serious a head injury or a
foot injury a head injury
the patreon community requested it you
requested it we're watching the office
checking out the medical scenes watching
them do some of these
new merch alert you could buy it right
there down below 100 of the proceeds are
going to charity click buy click and
watch let's do it
just say again really loudly uh what
happened okay
i burned my foot very badly on my
foreman grill
and i now need someone to come and bring
me into work how do you burn your
foot on a george foreman girl i enjoy
having breakfast in bed
i like waking up to the smell of bacon
sue me i don't really even recommend
eating bacon because it's a processed
meat which has a cancer risk i mean if
you have it every now and then it's not
the end of the world do not cook it in
bed while you're asleep with a hot
oh today i got up i stepped onto the
grill and i clamped down on my foot oh
that looks so fake by the way it would
be burnt it would be bloody there would
be skin peeling that looks like he just
like a little cat scratch i had the
worst experience when i was a kid
my sister was using one of these pots
the pot actually you used to steam and
like breathe over to help your sinuses
she asked me to bring it from the
kitchen after it boiled and as i'm
bringing it i
spill it all over my crotch oh my god
[Applause]
what was that oh he hit the pole
it's broken he can't oh my gosh oh
dwight
oh oh if you're throwing up immediately
after a car accident
that's a potential sign for serious head
trauma you better be calling 9-1-1
i am feeling better my body's literally
healing itself
it is amazing what the human body is
capable of when you have a powerful
brain
i ground up four extra strength aspirin
and put them in michael's pudding
i do the same thing with my dog to get
him to take his heartworm medicine
don't give people medicines that they're
not ready for
aspirin especially it has all sorts of
interactions with other medications
some people are sensitive to aspirin
like if i take an aspirin tablet my nose
bleeds
because it actually impairs platelet
function if god forbid they have a
procedure coming up that would be
detrimental children if you give them
aspirin they can develop rye syndrome
please don't just dose people with
aspirin just because you do the same
thing with your dog bear's good at
taking pills
oh okay i think we need to take him to
the hospital
oh no i'm pretty sure he has a
concussion oh now you feel some
compassion for him
he needs to go right now and you're his
emergency contact i think you should go
with him why don't you go with him
i barely know him i want michael to take
me i can't take you i don't have my car
why don't they just call 9-1-1 wake up
oh no don't do that let me help you do
it
okay thanks get up get the bath just
keep them away it smells like chicken
soup i know
when you have a concussion you need
cognitive rest less lights less sounds
less interaction
less movement you need your brain to
recover and the worst concussion is
actually your second concussion god
forbid you ever get a concussion in
let's say a game
do not go back into the game because the
second question is going to be much
worse what is more serious
a head injury or a foot injury a head
injury
so i'm ordering a cat scan what is that
the reason we get ct scans when
someone's involved in a car accident for
example is because if you have bleeding
in the brain it's an enclosed
environment
the skull actually prevents blood from
being able to displace the skin and as a
result pressure builds up and that could
be really problematic
outside of the fact that you're not
getting enough circulation to the brain
we actually followed a specific set of
guidelines known as the canadian head ct
guidelines you basically look at what
the patient experienced look at the type
of trauma they had what symptoms they're
experiencing you plug in the score and
it basically recommends whether or not
you should have a ct scan remember that
most ct scans expose you to as much
radiation as between 100 and 1000
x-rays so if you don't need that excess
radiation you really shouldn't be
getting it i'm having contractions but
they're irregular and far apart
so i'm not really in labor i'm near
labor
sometimes you can have false
contractions when you get closer called
braxton hicks contractions sometimes
they're not sure that's why they call
our on-call answering service and we
give them some guidance
labor can last weeks then they take your
insides out and they just plop them on a
table
and sometimes epidurals don't work you
can poop yourself
a lot of people poop during deliveries i
think i delivered like 30
maybe 40 babies during my residency
training i would put the poop rate
somewhere around
60 70 safety of the baby and safety of
the mother
most important most important most
important not the poop never thought i'd
say that statement
oh hey hey um should i bring a
dictionary to the hospital the hospital
will provide dictionaries bring a
thesaurus do you need a dictionary or
thesaurus and a hospital this is
ridiculous
get away no no no do i let jim do that
please okay i didn't know we had a tape
measure
we don't was he going to measure her
cervix
dilation with that we did not put tape
measures inside human bodies to measure
anything
again another statement i never thought
i would make damn's doing great
uh she's 10 inches dilated now sorry
meters
centimeters 10 meters dilated she's 30
feet dilated
and she's also fully effaced which i
don't know what that is
if he's a baby it's only been 16
19 hours albert room d1 all right
family only beyond this point thank you
it actually says patients and staff only
normally we have a check-in desk where
uh visitors have to check in and then we
check to see if it's a good time for
them to come in
we don't just let people barge in the
midst of a delivery babe she's so
beautiful crying baby means a healthy
baby
why is he smoking a cigar yeah
that's right it's a baby yeah you
shouldn't smoke in a hospital where
there's oxygen tanks ready
that's called the burrito technique very
important to learn early on because it
helps coddle the baby and helps them
sleep
careful though you don't want to break
it she's not gonna just
ah i got it just the other day i had uh
first-time parents come in they're
nervous and they're good nervous because
they're excited they want to do the
right thing
they're asking a bunch of questions but
it's awesome because then the baby comes
in for sometimes a newborn weight check
or sometimes they come in right away at
the two-month
first visit for vaccinations then four
months and six months and you get to see
the baby grow like that
it just it's one of the most fun parts
about being a doctor i just i can't tell
if she's getting anything
really it doesn't feel right well you
you're pushing the milk out right how
would one do that
wasn't it it's kind of like a one no you
don't push milk out the baby has to
latch and sometimes it's a process
the baby has a tongue tie the breast
anatomy sometimes it can be problematic
but it's all solvable we have lactation
specialists that meet with the moms
perhaps they can do some supplementation
especially early on it really depends on
each individual case
but the general recommendation is to be
breastfeeding your child fire
not real this was merely a training
exercise
what so what have we learned
oh come on it's not real stanley don't
have a heart
no no no check for a pulse call for help
if he's not
pulsating and he's not breathing chest
compressions just compress his chest
compression
andy a throne for your harness
i'm not sitting in a wheelchair no no no
no debate you were going to sit in that
wheelchair
you actually don't want to be sitting in
a wheelchair when you don't want to
that could actually decondition your
heart your body you want to be as active
as possible to the safest degree
why because you actually are training
your heart you're burning calories
you're keeping your metabolism up all
these things are really positive to
decrease cardiac event risk
especially when you've already had a
first heart attack abc
okay and that stands for airway
breathing
and circulation okay i threw in the
compressions just because i love the
compressions because if there's no
circulation what do you do
i heard you say it i can't keep doing
this forever
it's been 20 seconds two minutes
call it call it no you do it until you
realize that
it is futile just to make it clear i
feel like this gets confused
for most people when they watch these
shows if someone has a heart attack it
doesn't always mean that they need chest
compressions i've literally seen someone
discuss this before
where they're like oh my god my family
member's having a heart attack start
chest compressions
no no no yes heart attacks can sometimes
lead to your heart stopping where you
need chest compressions
not all heart attacks need chest
compressions persons awake and alert
they don't need chest compressions
you're losing them oh those are bad
chest compressions not deep enough
too fast you want to do it to the tune
of 100 beats per minute there's a lot of
famous songs that you could do too
i like staying alive i would sing it i'm
not trying to get demonetized
okay too fast everyone we need to pump
at a pace of 100 beats per minute
oh okay that's uh hard to keep track how
many is that per hour
[Laughter]
check for an organ donor card if he has
one we only have minutes to harvest he
has no wallet i checked
he is an organ donor he is yeah give me
some ice in a styrofoam bucket
whoa here we go did he just whip out a
knife i feel like a banana
when office parties get buck wild i also
don't know he could have injured his
testicular
area i was dancing and i did a split and
i landed on my car keys in my pocket oh
i did not expect that to be the
diagnosis what is the icd-10 code for
that what do you think is the worst
story crashed a car because of a tiny
spider
or tore scrotum while dancing don't know
click here to watch my reaction of
friends medical scenes one of my
favorite shows and don't forget to buy
some merch to help support americare's
that's down below
as always stay happy and healthy
you